SPEAKER: Please welcome to
the stage, Baba Brinkman.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
Straight out of Canada,
not straight out of Compton.
I started rapping, but
not for lack of options.
I was raised by some
real environmentalists.
I lived in the bush and planted
trees with the family biz.
And I ain't talking
about Flatbush.
I'm talking Bush camps in
the Canadian backwoods.
I was born in a
forest in a log cabin,
and still I ended up rapping.
How the hell did that happen?
Well, the first rap I wrote
was about planting trees,
and how I did it so
quick that nobody
could plant as fast as me.
So make sure you live
the lifestyle you're
repping, because a rhyme is
nothing without fact checking.
Every year of my life
was a new chapter
on my path to become the
first peer-reviewed rapper.
In college I studied the rhymes
of dead authors-- Shelley,
Byron, Blake, Pope,
Herik, Skelton, Chaucer.
Eliot's "Love Song of
J. Alfred Prufrock,"
but I was more into the
thug songs of Tupac,
another young rapper
descended from Europeans.
But at 19, you shouldn't
stop you from MC-ing,
like when I say
hip, you say hop.
Hip--
AUDIENCE: Hop.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) Yeah, hip--
AUDIENCE: Hop.
BABA BRINKMAN: Yeah,
when I say hip,
everyone actually says hop.
Hip--
AUDIENCE: Hop.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) Hip--
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) Tree hugging
Canadian, we don't know
what to make of him.
People heard me rapping,
always thought I was an alien.
I had a passion to grab a
mic and control it, ya'll.
I wasn't trying to play
a role, Rachel Dolezal.
I tried gangster rap, but
my heart just wasn't in it.
So I wrote a bunch of rhymes
on some stuff that's academic.
And then I got recruited
by a couple of researchers
to synthesize their work into
a bunch of my sweet verses.
That's when I really started
to find my groove and chase it.
Pioneering hip hop
science communications.
Aesop, the living legend,
listened to my music and said,
that's the kind of
rap white people
should be doing-- science rap.
The final frontier,
uncharted territory
for those who find
themselves here,
because the public is
skeptical of science findings.
And they're equally skeptical
of the fact that I'm rhyming.
In both cases, evidence
is insufficient.
You gotta hit people
emotionally to get them with it.
If reality contradicts
a person's worldview,
it takes persistence for
the message to get through.
Like when I say
confirmation, you say bias.
Confirmation--
AUDIENCE: Bias.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) Confirmation--
AUDIENCE: Bias.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) Confirmation--
AUDIENCE: Bias.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) Confirmation--
AUDIENCE: Bias.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) Yeah,
that's the sound of hip hop
for me, ya'll.
But climate change?
Oh, no topic is more divisive,
except for a Canadian science
rapper's existence.
So let's begin with an open
mind to both the science
and to me being dope
with rhyme-- dope enough
to get you open
off it, dope enough
to get invited to perform at
the Climate Conference in Paris
for all the national delegates.
I was there to rap about climate
and capture its relevance,
because people
find it difficult.
It's so political,
fiscal, and geophysical.
Agreement is pivotal.
John Kerry's in a meeting,
negotiating a treaty.
I'm there like, damn, they must
be desperate if they need me.
One month after, a major
attack by ISIS, and all they're
talking about is
the climate crisis.
And how do we get the word out?
Throw a concert and stick to the
facts, no fossil fuel sponsors.
I got this.
I'm the man for the job.
And if you want to come along,
then people put your hands up.
The world is full
of the problems that
are not easy to solve, and this
is how I get people involved.
BABA BRINKMAN: I mean
it is optional really.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
But yeah, see it's
not easy to solve, but this
is how I get people involved.
BABA BRINKMAN: OK,
here's an easier one.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
If you're with it,
nod your head to the beat.
Climate change is real.
Nod affirmatively.
See, I got you into it.
You participated.
Now whatever I say
next, you're implicated.
So let's see what climate
change communication would
sound like if rappers were
in charge of the sound bites.
A'ight.
BABA BRINKMAN: Let's
take it back to Paris.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) Yo, Paris.
You want a new
definition of hardcore?
Check out the international
climate report.
They say the world is getting
warmer, unequivocally.
And the oceans have
increased 30% in acidity.
And 90% of the warming trend
is oceanic and concentrated
in the Arctic.
Nobody panic, but the level
of greenhouse gases in the air
is higher now than it's
been in millions of years.
We added more than a trillion
tons of CO2 to the atmosphere,
and it's going to be centuries
before some of the gases clear.
I'm dropping science,
unvarnished, unbiased,
but I don't blame you if
your instinct is to deny it,
because we evolve to
prioritize immediate threats.
If it bleeds, it leads.
That's what the media says.
So let the gangster-esque
rap music paint a picture,
and I'll hit you with some
evidence-based predictions.
Get ready for wars, famines,
droughts, floods, hurricanes,
heat waves, murders, thugs,
chaos, refugees, stress,
disease, extinction,
disaster, IPCC.
Hollywood summer blockbusters
can't touch this.
I get my thrills from the
latest reports published
by the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change, formed
in 1988 to get the
science straight.
Now they dropped the
fifth assessment,
and the data's up to date.
So allow me to summarize--
bad things on the way.
Higher emission, sea level
rise, dire predictions,
on target for disaster,
movie style predicaments.
In Copenhagen we set a
limit of two degrees,
but that's still enough
to disintegrate major ice
sheets over the course of
centuries or maybe decades.
Yeah, some of the details
are still up for debate.
They fluctuate between certain
disaster and likely disaster,
slow and steady or
higher and faster.
Consensus, it's the
lowest common denominator,
which means it's probably going
to be way worse than the wars,
famines, droughts,
floods, hurricanes,
heat waves, murders, thugs,
chaos, refugees, stress,
disease, extinction,
disaster, IPCC.
So be afraid.
Be very afraid, but we're not
despite what the scenarios say.
And the effect of
talking about it
is visible yawning and
occasionally changing
our behavior microscopically.
And even those who
get it tend to get it
logically but not viscerally,
so we're navigating myopically.
The threat is existential.
It's not environmental.
And your individual
response is inconsequential.
Only coordination
of our whole species
is going to keep coastal
cities from sinking
below the deep seas.
And when was the last time a
solution included all of us?
Geophysics is at the
mercy of geopolitics.
Climate change communicators
keep it positive.
People need to feel like
they still have options.
And we do have options.
Either we find a
solution or we stick
with the business as
usual level pollution
and get used to the wars,
famines, droughts, floods,
hurricanes, heat waves, murders,
drugs, chaos, refugees, stress,
disease, extinction,
disasters, IPCC.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: Welcome to
the History Channel, ladies
and gentleman.
I'll be your host,
Baba Brinkman.
And this afternoon's
special will
be on this theory of
climate science discoveries.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) So let's
take it back 200 years
to the 1800s up in here,
when we only had 290 CO2 parts
per million in the atmosphere.
We had one billion
homosapiens on the planet,
trying to get their groove on.
And soon lots of
them would thanks
to Industrial Revolution.
Back when the steam engine
had just been invented,
and nothing was electric except
the spirit of the times--
progress.
And driven by the
scientific method,
Joseph Fourier was a
Frenchman, a physicist,
and a mathematician.
He discovered the fact
that the atmosphere
acts like a blanket
for heat retention.
The greenhouse effect
first described in 1824.
Visible light from the sun
meets little resistance inbound,
because the size of the
wavelengths is hella tight.
But then when it
hits the Earth, it
emits infrared radiation
with longer waves
and that you're
trapped and bounce back
when they try to escape on
their way back up into space.
And climate deniers today,
from Ted Cruz to Rand Paul
to Bobby Jindal, might say,
bounce back off of what?
Introducing John Tyndall.
In the 1860s
Tyndall investigated
methane and CO2 and water vapor
to see whether any of them
block infrared radiation,
and they all do.
But methane and water
vapor don't stick around
in the atmosphere for long.
It took a Swedish genius
to identify carbon dioxide
as a regulator,
Svante Arrhenius.
1896 Svante did the math.
If you cut the CO2
levels in half,
you'll end up with
a four to five
degree temperature drop
all across the map.
But if you double it, he
calculated a temperature
escalation of five
or six degrees,
because water vapor increases
with heat radiation.
And that feeds back
to increase the heat.
Of course in 1896, CO2
emissions were pretty moderate,
so they thought it would
take a couple thousand
years to double the
concentration when
they thought of it.
But you've got to
give it to Svante.
He predicted five
or six degrees,
and that's within the
warming range predicted today
by the IPCC.
Now in 1927, Arrhenius died a
celebrated Swedish civilian.
And three years later the
population of planet Earth
exceeded 2 billion.
In 1938, a British engineer
by the name of Guy Calendar
discovered a rise
in carbon dioxide
and also measured a
rise in temperature.
In 1958, Roger Revelle
demonstrated that the oceans
couldn't take care of it.
He said, humans are
now carrying out
a massive geophysical
experiment.
In 1960, Charles Keeling
did some measurements
on Mauna Loa of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere.
And every year the
level appeared to go up.
It was rising at a steady rate,
the same rate as emissions
from us burning oil and coal.
Also in 1960, the population
hit 3 billion souls.
Now it's 56 years later.
More than 7 billion of
us are in the same boat,
all hooked on fossil
fuels like a drug.
And how are we going to quit?
Just say no.
There's no easy answers.
There's just the truth
and its inconvenience,
but don't tell me the
science is recent.
The easy answer is [INAUDIBLE].
Look, we've been up on this.
The effect can be
traced back centuries.
The question is, how do
we restrict that effect
to two or less degrees?
We set a carbon budget.
We set a cap.
And we stay within
the limit, or else we
can expect a catastrophic
greenhouse effect.
And that's physics.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: All right.
We can't make this
too abstract, so I'm
going to have to implicate
myself in the climate equation
as well.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) Look.
Forgive me for producing
some emissions of pollution,
but this rhythm and
the music is my living.
When I do it, I get paid.
Yeah, it's been a decade
since I've had a day job,
and I did it my way
like Frank Sinatra,
just kicking up a racket.
I could be at a university
teaching classes,
but this is more
fun than teaching.
Look at the people I've reached.
I've been around the world.
I fly to Europe for the
weekend, do a gig in California
before I fly to New Zealand.
Encyclopedic, Rolling
Stone, pinch me.
I'm dreaming.
And you can check my status.
Got a US visa, O-1 artist of
extraordinary achievement.
This is all I've ever wanted.
People, I'm living the life.
In the past five years,
150 flights, 15 countries,
40 states and provinces,
and as for carbon emissions,
I'm off the charts with it.
Fossil fuel is how I got
here, both to entertain you
and in my career.
If you're earning something,
then you're burning something.
Prosperity is driven
by internal combustion.
So where my fossil
fuel ballers at?
If you're burning
something, holla back.
Yeah, where my fossil
fuel ballers at?
If you're burning
something, holla back.
BABA BRINKMAN: What?
Nobody's going to holler
back in this whole room?
This is a Western democracy.
Your carbon footprints
are massive.
If ballers exists, they're you.
Let's confess.
I'll go first.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) I've been
burning the hydrocarbons at both
ends, burning to make money,
and burning to spend.
And no one tells
me how to dispose
of my own property,
a globe trotting solo
artist with total autonomy.
This is what I am.
Fossil fuel is a part of me.
It powers 80% of
the global economy.
In other words, if
you have some money,
it's got oil stains on it.
Your hands are bloody.
And if you don't believe
me, go ahead and do a study.
Pimping ain't easy.
You better ask somebody.
Cooking with gas is pimping.
Driving a car is pimping.
Energy consumption is pimping.
Look at how we're living.
Gangsta compared to
horse and buggy days.
Cranking up the air
conditioner on muggy days.
Not freezing to
death in the winter.
If energy consumption
is a sin, I'm a sinner.
Life is good.
It's better than it used to be.
Let the good times roll.
Fossil fuels are cheap.
That's how we stay hella major.
Prosperity is the
bomb, player hater.
So where my fossil
fuel ballers at?
If you're burning
something, holla back.
Come on.
If you're burning
something, holla back.
Yeah, if you're burning
Where my fossil fuel ballers at?
If you're burning
something, holla back.
BABA BRINKMAN: That's good.
It's good to be honest, right?
It feels good to be honest.
Wait.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
Turn off the lights.
Conserve power.
Everything goes dark.
It's Earth hour.
We're taking action
on climate change.
All together now back
to the Stone Age.
In the meantime,
I'll be up in Vegas
illuminated, laughing
at you player haters.
Face it.
Balling is part of our nature.
Embrace it.
You love energy wasting.
Would you rather be living
large and comfortably,
or in a shack burning
dung for heat?
Some people don't have
a choice, but you do.
So don't hit me with
any hypocritical voodoo
about trying to reduce
my footprint voluntarily.
I'm trying to make ends.
I can't let them barely meet.
I'm always trying to get
more gigs and fly more.
I got a wife and a
daughter to provide for.
And maybe one day
solar will supply us.
I hope so.
It's better for global climate.
Just don't make me choose
between solar and diapers,
and don't make me switch
off my amplifiers.
So where my fossil
fuel ballers at?
If you're burning
something, holla back.
Come on.
Where my fossil fuel ballers at?
Be honest.
If you're burning
something, holla back.
Where my fossil fuel ballers at?
Get loud.
If you're burning
something, holla back.
We got Mother
Nature on her back,
but it's a one time thing.
Never call her back.
Holler.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: Anyone hollering
back at that filth should
be deeply ashamed of themself.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) La
de da de, we likes to party.
Fossil fuel ballers
ain't bothering nobody.
So what you talking about,
toes getting stepped on?
The top baller of
all time is Exxon.
CO2 from their
products-- add it up.
Exxon pollutes more than Canada.
So don't be surprised.
They write checks
to climate skeptics.
That just makes sense.
I mean, I guess we're all a
little bit skeptical, right?
Otherwise, how would we
get well rested at night?
But it might surprise you
that Exxon knew what they told
the public was just not true.
Internal memos going
back to the 70s show
they studied the
question scientifically
and recognized the
consensus on the topic
that rising emissions
would be catastrophic.
They must have thought their
pipelines would puncture,
because they re-engineered
their own infrastructure.
The offshore rigs for sea
level rise, they raise them up
while still telling lies
about how oh, the science is
inconclusive to justify moving
to low carbon solutions.
We can delay action on
climate change for decades.
Who says there's
no time to waste?
Cha-ching.
Now several Attorneys
General are investigating
Exxon for being criminal.
And that's not political.
That's greed and fraud.
It kind of makes me
wish I believed in God,
because then I'd believe
in a hell for them
to go to and choke on fumes
and reap what they sowed you.
Now I'm feeling radical.
I'm aligning with
activists, left wingers,
like His Holiness, Pope Francis.
I never thought I'd
get into religion,
but this pope has
animal magnetism.
And that behavior is crazy
despicable, so Francis,
hit them with a papal
and [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
[CHANTING LATIN]
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) Et cetera.
[CHANTING LATIN]
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
Praise God, the Creator.
[INAUDIBLE] these
techno capitalists
don't want to mess with me.
They just picked an epic
rap battle of history.
They're trying to defend carbon.
I'm the Holy Sea.
I'm the pope.
This world is a
paradise, and we're
degrading it with our dominant
technocratic paradigm.
It's time for an
ecological conversion.
I'm as sure of that as I'm sure
the Lord was born of a virgin.
This Earth is our home.
There's nowhere else to go.
We're worshiping a false
god, unlimited growth.
We're poisoning the oceans
and the air with carbon.
We're making a golden calf
out of the free market.
But we're part of this world.
We're created out of its dust.
If we don't put limits on our
appetites, they diminish us.
The root cause of global
warming and inequality
is rampant consumerism,
spiritual poverty.
I'm the first pope
with a sense of rhythm.
At the heart of my faith
is environmentalism.
As a Christian, I can say that
today's market fundamentalism
is worse than any fundamentalism
found in religion.
But radical change is coming.
Stop ignoring the problem.
The most prosperous are
destroying the global commons.
While the most vulnerable
watches, the sea level rises.
That's a sure path to mutual
destruction and violence.
Anything less than a
total shift in mentality
is nothing less than selling our
collective soul for a salary.
Worshiping gold is a fallacy.
Stop asking for more.
Stop feeding your appetites
off of the backs of the poor.
It's a moral
imperative to step back
from self-destruction and reform
the whole system of production
and consumption.
Rich countries owe poor
countries in ecological debt.
They block international action
out of national interest.
Selfish individual
consumers driven by greed.
Selfish companies fight to
protect their subsidies.
Selfish countries obsessed
with economic development.
Whatever we do next,
history will remember it.
And don't trust market
solutions like cap and trade.
That's a trick to
keep polluting.
Even if you have
to pay, and those
who say we need population
control are dodgy.
We could feed 10 billion
easily with greater equality.
It's not about
government policy.
It's about changing
consciousness.
No technocratic fix for
sustained obnoxiousness.
These aren't just my views.
They're also Jesus'.
We need to protect nature,
ya'll, and also fetuses.
I had to slip that in in case
you forgot I was Catholic.
But mostly, we're protecting
the poor from the affluent
and protecting this
earth, our common home,
from the tyranny of
unlimited economic growth.
So point to the sky where
the carbon is accumulating,
and point to the ground where
the carbon needs to stay.
And point to the left
where our political future
lies, and point to the right,
which is resistant to change.
Come on, everybody.
Point to the sky where the
carbon is accumulating.
Good.
Now point to the ground where
the carbon needs to stay.
Now point to the left-- no, your
left-- where our future lies.
Yeah, and point to the right,
which is resistant to change.
Good.
Now faster.
Point to the sky, and
point to the ground.
And point to the left,
and point to the right.
Faster again.
Point to the sky.
Point to the ground, point to
the left, point to the right.
[CHANTING LATIN]
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) Only
God can judge me, only God.
Only God can judge me now.
OK, so that one was a
little bit blasphemous,
but only God can
judge my sacreligion.
That's why I don't pay it
no mind, because blasphemy
is a victimless crime unlike
desecration of the planet.
So I bet Francis
will understand it.
Our Father who art
in the Vatican,
teach me to be a green advocate.
Must we abandon
capitalism and replace it
with some other
financial system?
That seems extreme, but I look
to your guidance on climate.
Show me the
spiritual side of it.
Transformational
change of heart.
Your local community,
that's the place to start.
So change your light bulbs.
Put up solar panels.
Recycle more.
Be nice to animals.
Ride your bike.
Plant trees every day.
Stop driving solo
in the carpool lane.
OK, I did all of that.
That was easy.
Am I done?
Can I keep watching TV?
What?
It's not enough?
Emissions are going up?
And the whole economy is
driven by burning stuff?
I mean, are we going
to make people own it,
or just wait for some kind
of come to Jesus moment?
The challenge is to
break habits of waste
and maximize freedom
in matters of taste.
So let's do what it takes.
Let's replace capitalism with
a more compassionate system
or just a more compassionate
version of capitalism.
Look.
As long as my job doesn't
have to stop-- people,
I got a crowd to rock.
Responsibilities, you can't
yank the plug on the vibe.
You feeling me?
But the bottom line is
when it comes to rhyming,
I would not stop this
show to save the climate.
I'm rocking till
they make me stop.
Climate change or
not, I make it hot.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: I'd just
like to assure everyone here
that I would stop the show to
save the planet if I thought
it would really help.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
Scientists are telling us
that we're standing
on a precipice,
and we have to convert
the global economy
and make it emissionless.
And those emissions are
caused by every single one
of our jobs.
Every one of us contributing
carbon emissions to the smog.
For instance, if I
write a rhyme trying
to describe climate change,
and it's hot so it catches on,
someone's going to fly me
someplace to perform it.
And the appeal of
that is enormous.
It's not an option
for me to turn down
work for global warming,
because I make it hot.
Yeah, people say
my rhymes are dope.
I twist words until
they're unrecognizable.
I make it hot.
I make it heezy for sheezy.
So hot even climate change
skeptics will believe me.
I make it hot, like
the temperature
it needs to be before the Tea
Party will believe the IPCC.
I make it hot.
I liquefy the
Greenland Ice Sheets,
seven meters of sea level rise.
That'll do nicely.
And yeah, humans are adaptable.
And we can toughen
up, but that response
ignores people who feel like
it's already tough enough.
Make a list of countries that
nobody visits as a tourist.
They have low carbon emissions.
The richest inflicted
this on the poorest.
We did it by heating our
houses and feeding our spouses
and flying and driving
places and having
no patience for power outages.
The Pope calls it
anthroprocentric.
He calls it obnoxious,
but I got work to do.
And work takes energy to
accomplish, and I make it hot.
Yeah, I turn up the
heat on the crowd.
You make it hot, too, though, so
don't try to be weaseling out.
I make it hot like
the African sun,
like the paleo scene,
eocene, thermal maximum.
I make it hot.
Feel that bass when it vibrates.
Hot like the permafrost
releasing methyl hydrates.
I make it hot like a
planet with low albedo,
like me rocking a trench coat
on a beach instead of a Speedo.
Hot with no apologies, but
still I'm feeling a lot of grief
for the impact my lifestyle
has on the planet's ecology.
My carbon footprint is
bigger than cryptozoologies.
I'm talking Loch Ness
Monster, so I'm not
at peace, because the aggregate
effect of every decision I'm
making is tragic.
But I can't just quit.
They say that we're
carbon emission addicts.
But that's just glib.
You want me to live
in poverty abject?
And if I did, what happens to
greenhouse gases on average?
If I quit and you don't, it's
still hell in a hand basket.
A traffic jam with
no plan of action,
fantastic, this is
a classic arms race
that we're trapped in.
It's ominous.
Self-interested party stuck
in a tragedy of the comments.
The problem is caused by our
collective emissions of carbon,
but the person who emits
is not the person emissions
are harming.
So that's a failure
of the market.
Like everyone is incentivized
to pollute as much
as they can get away with,
and catch a free ride.
So it's no surprise to
see emissions on the rise
when the cost of burning
fossil fuel is externalized.
It's effectively subsidized.
It's paid for by the victims
of the eventual climate impacts
caused by our emissions.
And Bill McKibben
and the guardian
have been targeting investments
like dirty energy is
the new tobacco, so keep your
distance from anybody making
a profit off of fossil fuels.
Cool, I'm down with the boycott.
I'm just boycotting myself,
too, because I make it hot.
Yeah, I cause a heat wave.
How about nine degrees
hotter than the hottest ones
these days?
I make it hot like
climate refugees.
Picture a hot 100 million
displaced Bangladeshis.
I make it hot.
I spit flames, rap metaphors.
A five alarm blaze killing
the last Redwood forest.
I make it hot.
How about I make it six
degrees, causing the extinction
of 40% of species?
Hot.
So what are we left with?
A speeding train with no brakes,
some kind of a death wish,
a scientific
consensus that we're
standing on a precipice
and a population
with no idea of how to
reduce their emissions.
Some people do offset
their footprint voluntarily
with the milk of human
altruism-- hope, faith,
and charity, but that's
not going to cut it.
It's not counterproductive,
but we've
got a global carbon budget.
And it's globally busted.
And there are
hundreds of gigatons
that you would have to offset.
You might as well
donate your piggy banks
to the national debt.
I ain't got no spare change to
donate to carbon offsetting.
I don't even want to
calculate my footprint.
I find it upsetting.
It's like the medieval
Catholic Church back
when it was indulgence selling.
If you get a Big
Mac and a Diet Coke,
your belly's still swelling.
But here's what I'm willing.
I'm willing to pay a
tax, like a fee that's
calculated against
my carbon impacts
and globally harmonized to
switch incentives around
and make sure most of
that carbon stays safely
under the ground.
But I'm not going to pay it,
not unless you all pay it, too.
That way I can be
sure that you'll
do what you say you'll do.
How about everyone
has to pay it?
No free riders allowed.
No international pact with
the US or China left out.
You can invest it
in green R&D, or you
can dividend it back to me.
But either way, I won't be
happy until the day they're
carbon taxing me,
'cause then I can
make it hot without
ever feeling a chill.
I'm just sick of this
guilt trip killing my high
when I'm feeling a
thr So I make it hot.
I get your emotions aroused.
If we can't make
those hot, we're not
going to keep the oceans down.
So let's make it hot.
People, let's turn up
the heat on polluters
trying to catch a ride on
all the rest of us for free.
I make it hot on the mic
and in my social life
when I agitate for my friends
to agitate for a carbon price.
BABA BRINKMAN: And that's
how you make it hot.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: All right.
Welcome to Talks at Google,
ladies and gentlemen.
This afternoon's seminar
will be on the future
of global capitalism and how
you, like me and my hedge fund
managers, can profit from it.
Now before we begin the
seminar, the meat of it,
I'd just like to see
who's in the house today.
So raise your hand if
you consider yourself
to be a pro-market person.
Do we have any
pro-market people?
Look at that.
More than half.
All right, cool.
Put your hand up if you think we
should have an ambitious target
to reduce CO2 in the atmosphere.
Where my ambition
target people at?
Look at that.
Everybody.
All right.
Now put your hand
up if you think
carbon pricing of
some sort is how
we should get there-- carbon
taxes, cap and trade, whatever?
All right.
Just a little over half.
Cool.
I just want to tell you about
the concept of a bubble.
We may have something
called a carbon bubble, so
let me tell you
about this bubble
and how the bubble works.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
The bubble's value
is based on our perception
of what it's worth,
but if that consensus changes,
that bubble's going to burst.
So we should try to
get ahead of the curve.
Back before the crash of 2008,
a few people saw that bubble
and knew how it would break.
That was debt obligations
on top of debt obligations,
collateralized and traded,
bloated and overinflated.
Bad debt was being sold
as AAA rated asset.
Hindenburg, don't be
surprised when it crashes.
Well, now we've got another
bubble on our hands.
And it's a hell of a lot worse
than sub-prime mortgage scams.
This is a carbon bubble,
a whole economic engine
on the collision course to
bankrupt the climate system.
Risky business, but who's
going to give us a bailout?
This global civilization is
a bit too big to fail now.
The carbon economy
is an insolvent bank,
so the government's got
to be part of the fix.
Ask Dodd-Frank.
I'm not a businessman.
I'm a business, man.
I need a carbon price to
handle my business, damn.
BABA BRINKMAN: So
again, put your hand up
if you're pro-market.
Just taking a poll here.
Put your hand up if you
want an ambitious target.
That's pretty much everybody.
Put your hand up if you
want a price on carbon.
All right.
Let's try to move the
needle in the room a bit.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) A business
doesn't have to close
down to reduce emissions.
It just needs a level playing
field with its competition.
An economic growth can continue.
We don't have to stop it.
It might slow down a bit, but
alternatives are catastrophic.
So far the most popular is
this cap and trade system.
That's a decreasing total limit
on greenhouse gas emissions,
but with tradable permits
auctioned off or given away.
So companies who innovate
to reduce emissions
get paid, which is great,
unless it's only big business
capped in charge.
That doesn't go far enough.
What about tailpipes on cars?
That's why some countries go
with a carbon tax instead--
a flat rate at the source
where that fuel gets extracted.
And that's when clean energy
gets a lot more competitive.
And revenues get dividended
back to regular citizens.
And some of it gets invested
in the next round of inventions
to revolutionize
the energy system.
Picture it.
So get your hands up
if you're pro-market.
Get your hands up if you
want an ambitious target.
Get your hands up-- bounce
them just like that.
--if you want a price on carbon.
Yeah, let's get
the party started.
Ignoring climate change
is like investing
in derivatives in 2007.
It's not recommended.
The future is a shared resource.
Don't bet against it.
Bet on scientific literacy
winning elections.
We're trying to get to net
zero emissions by 2050.
Anything less is just
unacceptably risky.
But with the right
market incentives,
we'll find the way forward.
Carbon pricing can even pay to
protect surviving rain forests,
because if you
plant a new forest,
or close a coal
burning plant, that's
atmospherically equivalent
in its carbon content.
And deforestation is 17%
of emissions released.
So that carbon
price has to capture
what's sequestered in trees.
The price can be cap and
trade, or tax, or a hybrid.
One or the other or
both, so long as we
stabilize the climate.
And opportunity knocks for
the future masters of business
who embrace the
evolution of capitalism.
What?
So people, get your hands
up if you're pro-market.
Get your hands up if you
want an ambitious target.
want a price on carbon.
Let's get this green
capitalism party started.
BABA BRINKMAN:
Well, I'm not sure
how far I managed to move
the needle this afternoon,
but I do appreciate you
attending my seminar.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's just calm it down a
bit in here-- a little crazy.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) If
you invest in fossil fuels,
I feel bad for you, son.
I got 99 problems,
but that ain't one.
Hit me.
Slap me, and wake me up.
And some of the stuff is so
crazy I couldn't make it up.
So let's just all take
a second and contemplate
it-- a fossil fuel company
that's publicly traded.
What's a firm in the business
of fossil fuel really worth?
Its book value is based
on their proven reserves.
It's not the fuel they sell
to us and we burn right now.
It's the coal, gas, and oil
that's still underground.
Now technically, it's
worthless until it oxidizes.
But as soon as they find it,
it goes in their stock prices.
The top 200 companies
digging it and drilling it
are collectively worth
more than $7 trillion.
Did they forget the IPCC?
I thought we had an
agreement to keep this heat
increase below two degrees.
If so, we only get to release
around 560 gigatons by 2050.
Any disregard for that
budget is highly destructive.
Those are the facts
that we're stuck with.
The percentage of the budget
covered in proven reserves
determines how much we can burn
and what to keep in the earth.
So what's down there now
waiting to come to market?
Around 2,700 gigatons of carbon.
That's five times as much
as we can safely burn,
so investments manager
should be a bit concerned
that fossil fuel stock
prices are inflated.
Get your pensions out
before the industry craters.
Investing in fossil
fuels got to be a bad bet
if 80% of their stock
is a stranded asset,
like a warehouse
full of Kodak film
when digital crashed
the market, causing
a total loss of principal.
What a lack of principles.
What's on their
books can't be cashed
in unless the
whole planet cooks.
I used to put my faith in
spiritual transformation.
Now I'll put my
faith in legislation
to end this whole
fossil fuel charity bid
and make sure clean energy gets
up to parity with the grid.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: People, we're at
Google, so envision the future.
In it, you'll see me rocking
solar panels on my Tesla.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
Solar panels on my Tesla.
I'm rocking solar
panels on my Tesla.
Green tech Renaissance
better catch up.
Petroleum is oh, so prosaic.
I'm a player when it
comes to photovoltaic.
So three cheers
for the engineers.
80% price drop in
the past five years.
I've been to Germany.
It's kind of gray, but
half of their total power
is solar on sunny days, OK.
It's cheaper than
coal now in 20 states.
Haters hate, but they
can't stop the wave.
Hey.
And the next phase
of battery techs
got that solar flowing day
and night, and that'll be it.
We got a gravity
battery underground
charging up with the solar
water pump right now.
Every car, every house,
every business, every year.
Make the switch in ignition.
Switches will disappear.
I'm rocking solar
panels on my Tesla.
You say it.
I'm rocking solar
panels on my Tesla.
Use a gas guzzler?
That's messed up.
I'm rocking solar
panels on y Tesla.
Did I mention solar
panels on my Tesla?
Your turn.
AUDIENCE: I'm rocking
solar panels on my Tesla.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
You've got coal dust up
in your left lung.
I'm rocking solar panels on my--
AUDIENCE: Tesla.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) I'm
a fan of how the wind feels.
Windmills power whole cities
when you put them up in fields.
That's the new.
Fossil fuel is the old way.
Don't hate on wind
farms, Don Quixote.
What about nuclear?
That's what they asking me.
Hell of a lot better for
the planet than gasoline.
Some new investments made
can make it extra safe.
I'm thinking Bill Gates
probably should investigate.
Apollo moon shot,
scalable renewables.
We can't expect Elon
Musk to do on his own.
Cellulolytic, biofuel,
and carbon capture,
lifting CO2 out of thin
air just like the Rapture.
Gadgets to manufacture
and toys to play with that
make it pay when
pollution poisons evaded.
So come fly with
me on solar Cessnas
into a future of
affordable Tesla.
I'm rocking solar panels
on my Tesla hypothetically.
Here's a confession.
I drive a Honda
Civic, not a Tesla.
But if it wasn't
so expensive, I'd
get one and rock solar
panels on my Tesla.
Your turn.
Rocking solar
panels on my Tesla.
That's the future, ya'll,
solar panels on a Tesla.
Last chance.
I'm rocking solar
panels on my Tesla.
You got it.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: All right.
That one had kind of a
tricky new school rhythm.
This one's got more of
an old school rhythm.
If you know the words, say
the words along with me.
Everyone knows the words.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
You can get with this,
or you can get with that.
You could get with this,
or you could get with that.
But you should get with this,
because this is where it's at.
Yeah.
So get with this,
or get with that.
Let's see if we can
get with the math.
So what's your greenhouse
gas reduction target?
How about 20 tons of carbon.
That's what the average American
emits every single year.
Well, that's easy to fix.
The global average is only four
tons, and billions of people
are still trying
to get more stuff.
Just like your stuff,
and who are you to say,
or who am I to say that
they should have to wait?
So this is
everybody's party now,
and that's a shame, because
then it's nobody's party.
It's the same.
I want to do the right thing
right now, but then again,
I like my lifestyle.
And it can't be right for me to
give it up unilaterally while
y'all just live it up.
Frustration, first
inclination is
to put faith in
innovation to save us,
instead of trying to
rein in misbehavior.
But that's a risky wager.
Tell me, Google, how long
will it take innovation
to reverse one basic equation,
one perverse incentive where
dirty is cheap, and
clean is expensive.
Remember, this is
a physical system.
It doesn't give a damn about
your relative emissions,
or whether emissions
come from decadent
living or visiting
relatives at Christmas.
This is everything.
It's everything we manufacture--
concrete, steel, glass,
and plastic.
Whether or not you change
your little habits,
absolute emissions,
that's all that matters.
So you get with that--
business as usual.
Everybody wiggling through
their own loophole.
Or you can get with this--
an arms control agreement,
and if that's what you want,
then act like you mean it.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: So we're going
to get into the Q&A portion
of the afternoon in a moment.
So if you have a question
or comment about anything
I've been speaking on, I invite
you to step to the microphone.
And I really actually need
you to step to the microphone,
because I'm going to be relying
on your input to construct
the rest of the show.
The show's not over.
Every night I do this off
Broadway and have this Q&A.
And then I integrate people's
suggestions and ideas
into the show
improvisationally so
that it can become a complete
guide to the climate,
as far as you know, rather
than merely a partial guide.
So I need you now to
complete me by suggesting
things that I addressed
insufficiently,
or that I left out, or
things that you think
are crucial to a discussion
of climate change
and how to solve it.
So all right.
Number one, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, you said,
I think, in the last one
that nuclear is promising,
but very recent events
might be proving you wrong,
because PG&E just closed down
their nuclear plant right in
California, because they're
seeing that solar might
actually be cheaper.
BABA BRINKMAN: Yes, and
that's absolutely the case.
Solar is cheaper than nuclear.
There's pretty much
no unsubsidized
nuclear in the world
right now, and this
is old generation stuff.
The nuclear we're using
today is 50 or 60 years old,
which is why I referenced
Bill Gates, because he
has put together a private
investment group that
is exploring innovations around
next generation nuclear, which
I feel optimistic about.
But when people ask me, what
should we do with nuclear?
My answer is usually,
I don't think
we should spend any
government money on building
new 1950s nuclear plants.
Whether we should spend
government money on R&D,
developing the fast breeder
reactors in the next gen,
I think probably
not, because I think
government subsidies
could be better spent
on existing renewables that
can more effectively pick up
the slack.
But if private investors want
to take a bet on developing
something that will become
commercially viable,
I think that's a
really great thing.
And I applaud that
initiative, but I'm not
for government
sponsored nuclear.
It's a nuanced position.
Other comments?
I actually need the
input, otherwise
I'm going to have to freestyle
about nothing after this.
But make sure your
comments are substantive.
Don't just tell me words that
are difficult to rhyme with.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So Brett
Victor is a technologist
who worked with Al
Gore on his book.
And he has a really nice
bit about climate change
on his site.
And one of the things he
says is that batteries
aren't enough right now to power
the grid with just renewables.
Can you address that a little?
BABA BRINKMAN: Sure.
So most of the
battery technology
that's being used for
storing solo is lithium ion.
That's what the new
Tesla wall battery is.
And you can do a
house with that,
but I don't think you
can really do a city.
The thing that I
mentioned is the concept
of a gravity battery.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING) There's
a gravity battery underground.
BABA BRINKMAN: Maybe
not even underground,
because one thing
that you can do
is you can take solar, which
is only a daytime power source,
and use it to run pumps
to send water uphill.
And then that can create
hydro potential, which you
can release whenever you want.
So using the force of gravity
is a potential bridge solution.
I'm optimistic that within a
few years, or maybe decades,
there will be storage
technologies that don't require
these big geological solutions.
One of the gravity
battery concepts
is you actually just drill
a cylinder underground.
Drilling technologies,
they are existing.
You can just have a
huge slab of granite
that's floating in water, and it
just gets pumped up to the top
by solar.
And then it gets drawn
down to take power,
and that would be a feasible
way to store power as well.
But storage is an issue and
one of the reasons why people
are hesitant to give up on
fossil fuels and nuclear,
because they work
around the clock.
And wind and solar only
work at certain times,
but that's a crucial
piece of the puzzle, which
I'd love to see Google
help to solve as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BABA BRINKMAN: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I wanted to raise
climate change adaptability,
because keeping carbon
emissions under 2% is nice,
but a lot of countries
around the world,
such as Bangladesh
which you referenced,
have been physically losing
land for almost a decade if not
more.
And all these communities are
doing some pretty impressive,
remarkable stuff to live with
climate change and adapt to it.
I think that's a very
powerful message that
can be incorporated more.
BABA BRINKMAN: Yeah, thank you.
I was on the fence about how
much to emphasize that when
I was creating the
show, because I
think there is a sort
of inspirational triumph
over adversity side to telling
that part of the story.
And you're right.
It's totally necessary.
Several South Pacific Islands
just went underwater completely
for the first time, due to
climate change recently.
However, the deniers
and the contrarians
tend to overemphasize
adaptation,
because that's the sort of
libertarian, don't worry.
We don't have to do anything
about reducing emissions.
We can just invent
our way out of it,
because we're such good
engineers and builders.
And so I think there's a
real danger in over reliance
and over celebration
of adaptation.
I think it should be adaptation
where currently necessary.
But the reductive
ad extremio of that
is that we just don't have
to stop burning stuff.
And that actually
takes us beyond what
I think we can
technologically adapt to.
We can adapt to
inches, maybe feet,
but can we adapt to
meters of sea level rise?
That's something we've
never really tried before.
That's why I didn't focus on
that too much in the show,
but I think it is important.
It's just one of those ones that
needs a pretty solid footnote
when you talk about it.
AUDIENCE: Fair point.
Thanks.
BABA BRINKMAN: Thanks.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There
was a day recently
where Germany had to
actually credit users,
because their natural resources
produce so much energy
that they just get overwhelmed.
And people were
actually getting paid
to use the energy
in the country.
How would you change what
we're doing in the US
to start implementing
a policies--
I know this is a
very vague question.
But obviously America would
need to start somewhere.
Where would you start?
BABA BRINKMAN: Well, I think
there's a Stanford analysis.
I think it may be called
the Solutions Project, which
was a sort of
state by state plan
for transitioning to
all renewable energy
over the next few decades.
And that's available
to us as a plan.
Part of the reason I
focus on taxes and pricing
and regulation and policy
so much in this show
is because I think that's really
the key in the lock right now.
I think people
are actually going
to be more effective trying to
influence governments to change
their laws-- municipal,
state, or federal level--
or trying to
influence businesses.
I think we are in a LEED's gold
standard building right now.
Google made the decision to
make this a very low emissions
building, but Google
can afford it.
And that is one of
the key messages
is we have a general
problem of dirty is cheap,
and clean is expensive.
And not every company
is ready to jeopardize
their competitiveness
by doing that spend.
So I think the number
one thing that's
needed the most in the US is
a carbon pricing system, which
will then just change that
incentive structure so
that suddenly you don't have
to be poor by being virtuous.
You can actually do what's
right for your wallet
and the environment
at same time,
but that requires government
intervention at this point,
because innovation hasn't solved
that problem on its own yet.
I think there's a good
argument to make that it
will if you just let it happen.
Give us two or three decades.
I bet all renewables will be
cheaper than all fossil fuels.
The problem is we're already
over 400 parts per million
of CO2 in the
atmosphere, and that's
already creating a
creeping warming that's
going to melt a
lot of the sea ice
unless we reverse it and
stop it as soon as possible.
So when people ask
me, what should we do?
Especially in the United
States, I say, buy clean,
green products.
That's a good thing to do,
I guess, but on its own
it's not going to
be nearly enough.
Individual consumer choices
will make up such a small part
of the pie compared
to energy generation
and concrete manufacturing and
all the other big stuff that
really has to be done at the
legislative level, in my view.
Not every environmentalist likes
to hear that, but a lot of them
do.
All right.
So this is great.
This is the kind
of conversation I
wanted to start
the show to have,
so I guess the only way
to logistically integrate
it now is with a freestyle.
You guys want to
hear a freestyle?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BABA BRINKMAN: Here we go.
BABA BRINKMAN:
(RAPPING) In a moment
I'm going to
attempt to integrate
every single one
of your questions
into a freestyle rhyme.
But before I start
freestyling, I
have this little written
intro to preface it,
because a freestyle is not free.
A freestyle's regulated.
It's the rhyme and rhythm that
makes it lyrically innovative.
And freedom ain't free.
You want to hear a freestyle
that's really free.
Freestyle, it needs
some infrastructure.
So I want to voluntarily
really restrain it,
so you get something from it.
Here's a freestyle
that is literally free.
[GIBBERISH]
Yeah, I improvised every
syllable in that sequence,
but was the lack of
semantic content a weakness?
OK.
Here's a freestyle that's
slightly less free.
Intelligible words-- bird, bee,
watermelon seed, tree, sweet.
Those words came straight
off of the top of my dome,
but in retrospect, they
didn't have a point or a flow.
So I suppose when I
freestyle, it really
needs to have
parameters, so you can
tell the difference between
professionals and amateurs.
It's got to work rhythmically,
and sonically, and logically.
It's better off with better
laws, kind of like market
economies, because
freedom ain't free.
Freedom involves tradeoffs.
We don't want our bankers to
be free like Bernie Madoff.
Freedom ain't free.
Freedom for Cecil
the lion means you
got to take away the freedom
of dentists to buy him, people.
Freedom ain't free.
You say you want a free market.
I want a market free from people
dumping their garbage on me.
Freedom ain't free.
Now don't freak out, but
the whole rest of this flow
is about to be freestyle.
I'm at Google, so I guess
what I should do is geek out.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm a rap artist at
home always chilling.
I never been somewhere
that made me want
to work in an office building.
But now I do.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm spitting a
freestyle up in here.
I'm hoping I can
give a shout out
to all of the
software engineers.
Maybe software engineers could
see the problem and solve them.
They might even help us
deal with the next gen
nuclear problem.
That would be
pretty dope indeed.
That way we can
reciprocate, and that way
we wouldn't have to
wait for freaking
Microsoft and Bill Gates.
You guys can solve it.
Come on, quick.
You better analyze it.
I love this company,
because it's always
coming up with massive
new surprises indeed.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm always just saying, yes.
And I got to give a shout
out to my homebody who
gave a shout out to Bangladesh.
Bangladesh, man, they
got some serious sea
level rise problems.
I think in this country,
we've got a lot more options.
That's why, indeed, I'm just
always flipping these trees,
but that is a good case for us
having moral responsibilities
for the people who
didn't cause the problem
but suffering the consequences.
That's why the climate deniers
are full of a lot of denseness.
Yeah, indeed, I'm
flipping the free,
but even if I make a little
mistake over the rhythm,
that's mutation and evolution
introducing randomness
into the system.
Yeah, that's right.
Freestyle, you
know I'm a monster.
Check out the
simultaneous transcription
up on the teleprompter.
That's right.
It's crazy for her
when I bust a free.
There is no translator
on Earth that
could ever freaking keep up with
me, as I keep on spitting this.
Yeah, I'm analyzing it.
Freestyling it.
Yeah, that's right.
My freestyle's
full of surprises.
But my freestyle ain't
free not even to me,
because I am restraining
what I say simultaneously.
And people, freedom ain't free.
Freedom involves sacrifice.
If pollution causes harm,
pollution should have a price.
People, freedom ain't free.
On its own, freedom is chaos.
I want freedom like Picasso,
not like a baby with crayons.
Freedom ain't free.
Yeah, I hope you
like my freestyle,
even though you know
it's not entirely free.
Peace out.
[APPLAUSE]
BABA BRINKMAN: Thank you.
All right.
Here comes the grand finale.
Look.
Somebody told me that
climate is changing.
And all we can do is chill
out and watch as it warms.
BABA BRINKMAN: (RAPPING)
Somebody told me
that we can reverse it
by changing the stuff
we buy in stores, but
the stakes are enormous,
talking forest fires and storms.
So I'm thinking that
we can make changes
by changing the climate of
the norms, of what's cool
and what's taboo.
We have been in
this place before.
It's kind of like
segregation in the South,
before MLK kicked in the door.
It's kind of like
apartheid in South Africa
before Nelson
Mandela walked free.
It's kind of like
gay people trying
to get married in the
States before 2015.
Those laws all needed changing,
and so do the laws we have now.
Only this time, the laws
are passing oppression
down to your grandchild.
Now it's someone in a coastal
city and a developing nation
being treated unequal, because
one meter of sea level rise
displaces 100 million people.
But the climate is changing.
It doesn't feel the same
as it did five years ago.
People are starting
to open their ears.
They're ready to hear.
So here we go.
We know there's a limit to the
emissions our atmosphere can
safely carry.
So go tell people.
That's the carbon budget.
Anything above it
has to stay buried.
And that's going to take a
little bit of everything,
a little bit of
civil disobedience,
disruptive technology,
a little bit of digital media,
a hell of a lot of protecting
forests, and restoring
one's law to the ground,
and a total moratorium on
coal fired power plants.
Shut them down.
And the fracking of
natural gas is just as bad
when you factor production.
Every ounce you burn is
an act of destruction,
an act of injustice that
we are responsible for.
But what can individuals do?
Well, the climate is sensitive
to forcings and socially so
are you.
That's the climate of norms.
Look at us.
We're social animals.
Whether or not
your neighbors have
them is the best predictor of
you putting up solar panels.
You're not going to stop
people from competing,
or trying to keep
up with the Joneses.
But you might harness
those competitions
for clean energy explosions.
So we can get that
technology ready,
which the whole planet
is going to need, and be
able to afford when we get these
carbon pricing systems indeed.
That's going to take a
little bit of everything,
but we're going to have
to get there if we try.
When it comes to solving
this, the limit is the sky.
We've got to make this
change rapidly as possible.
How about without
crashing the economy
or shutting out
lights at a hospital?
This is like a civil
rights battle--
a righteous cause
for a generation.
You got to change laws
when they're unjust.
You can't just say,
please don't be racist.
And you can't just tell
people to voluntarily embrace
decarbonization.
That's been tried for decades.
Emissions are still escalating.
I found out about this situation
because my reading habits
are voracious.
I thought I could
help get the word out
thanks to my unique vocation.
I started rapping as
a teenager thinking I
might change the world.
I ended up rapping
for about a decade,
pretty much just chasing girls.
But if I change
one mind tonight,
or I move one person to
action, by my standards
that would be like the
definition of gangster rapping.
BABA BRINKMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So that is my
complete-- well, this
is a shortened
version of the show.
The show is running off-Broadway
until the end of July at least.
I'm working on recording
an album version.
We'll be doing a
tour in the fall.
And please spread
the word about what
I'm doing-- science
communication via rap--
but more importantly, spread
the word about climate change
being a crucial thing that
we need to take seriously.
Have it be a mainstream
political issue,
make it a voting deal
breaker, and just let's
not sweep this under
the rug anymore.
That'll make me happy.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]